منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه اكبر صدمه
تجاريه واقتصاديه شاهدها قطاع السفر الجوي
والطيران هي تفشي فيروس كورونا وبين ما
ننتقل الى عام 20 23 يتوقع الاتحاد النقل
الجوي الدولي لنتعرف قطاع الطيران ويكتسب
زخما في العام المقبل ويعود الى تحقيق
الاربعه على الرغم من تجديد الاقتصاد
العالمي مع ارتفاع هذا طلب عرض شركه اون
لاين زياده في الاجور التراكميه بنسبه
34% لطيارها على مدى ثلاث سنوات في عقد
جديد كما وعدت شركه الطيران التي تتخذ من
اتلانتا مقرا لها ان تتجاوز معدلات رواتب
طيارها مدراءهم في يونايتد وامريكان اون
لاينز بنسبه واحده في المئه على الاقل
يذكر ان تيار دلتا لم تتجدد عقودهم لما
يقرب من ثلاث سنوات بعد ان اصبح عقده قديم
قابله للتعديه في ديسمبر 2019 مما ادى الى
اخباطه
[موسيقى]
كما سمعنا هو كما يتردد تعا في كبير في
قطاع الطيران الاقتصاديا هل يمكن القول
انقطاع عاد الى مستويات ما قبل الجارحه
الان على مستوى العالم تقريبا التعافي هو
74% من ما كان عليه في 2019 عوده الحركه
الطيران بشكل عام ولكن طبعا في مناطق في
العالم تختلف عن غيرها مثلا امريكا هي
الاسرع نمو اليوم مثل ما شفنا في الخبر
دلتا رفعت رواتب الموظفين لانه التعافي في
امريكا بالنسبه للسفر المحلي واحد في
المئه اقل فقط من مستويات 2019
يعني فقط اقل من مستويات 2019 مقارنه ب17%
في اوروبا و57% في همم اسيا الان ليش امير
طبعا ارتفع وحده من العوامل كان هو ارتفاع
دولار مقابل باقي العملات طبعا الى زياده
السفر سواء محليا او عالميا همم ايضا هذا
مثل ما قراتي في الخبر هذا كل العوامل ادت
الى زياده الطلب والمنافسه على الوظائف في
قطاع الطيران وخصوصا الطيارين اللي كانوا
مظلومين يعني خصوصا في امريكا كانت
رواتبهم جدا قليله فيما يكلف يعني تكلفه
باهضه انه يتخرج كطياره 100,000 دولار
و1,500 ساعه طيب بدلنا نتحدث عن الوظائف
والطيارين قطاع التيار الامريكي اعلن عن
نقص حاد في الطياره هل الرواتب هي السبب
يا سمر وهل هو نقص عالمي للطيارين هو نقص
عالمي للطيران فعلا همم في المنطقه مثلا
عندنا نقص خلال السنه القادمه في الشرق
الاوسط ثلاثه الاف طيار حتى في منطقه حتى
في منطقتنا طبعا هنا بنفس الوقت هي فرصه
هو نفسه
الاتجاه لهذه الوظائف عندك على مستوى
العالم خلال ال 10 سنوات القادمه سيكون
هناك نقص 80,000 موظف في يعني طيار تحديدا
في عندك في امريكا فقط ثمانيه الاف نقص
بالطيارين ليش هذا النقص يصير اول شيء
لانه مثلا في امريكا هم مثل ما قلنا ما
كانوا يدفعوا لهم رواتب جيده وتكلف ايضا
القانون يتطلب 1500 ساعه تعمل في يورب
يتطلب القانون 250 ساعه عمل فقط براكتس
وارخص التكلفه من التخرج كم مدارس ك- طيات
ايضا اللي صار انه مؤخرا كرم هناك اعتماد
في امريكا الطيار الحربي بعد ما يتقاعد
منكم وانا طيار حربيه يذهب ليصبح طيار
مدني اليوم هناك اعتماد كبير على الدرونز
همم والطيارات المسيره فقط اقل الانخراط
في قطاع الاذريشن او الطيران الحربي في
امريكا ايضا اليوم يمكن لهذا التوجه حتى
في العالم العربي انه هناك دعوه وتشجيع
اكثر اللي دراسه هذا
القدوم الى هذا القطاع حتى هناك
اليوم الم من الاناث يدخلون في قطاع
الطياران ويتخرجون كالطيارات
[موسيقى]